somebody over here somebody hi uh just  quick question  my wife of 12 years recently divorced me  she's got psychological problems that's  what i assumed  too but she said it was because i never  consider her emotions and i'm  constantly cheating on her what was your  childhood like  uh what are you my therapist you'll  never get me to admit that what will get  debra to take me back  the answer is nothing nothing but of  course  i wouldn't tell you anyway what is your  problem man  i mean is it because you hated my novel  i i told you it was just an  early draft i thought the sex scenes  were really  good do you think i should just quit  writing then so mcdonald's announced  that they were hiring  i can't believe i thought you could  actually help me i feel like i'm gonna  puke  we grew up calling it dry farts  [Music]